that is a lie yeah we're getting real
here we're getting honest lie lie right
this week we are going to attempt to be
a hundred percent honest with each other
can we do it you'll have to watch to
find out I feel like that's one of the
most important things about a
relationship if it's not gonna hurt
Steve or hurt myself to say a little
white lie like I ate a certain food for
dinner all right snapchat and you sleep
talking for six months I've been
recording you and like putting them up
onto a snapchat story how long have you
been doing this for just a for six
months six months are you kidding me
yeah I'm still sour about that by the
way I don't wait not you're waiting
you're too honest sometimes I wish you
would wait like just be like damn you
look great
even if I don't do you might lie
sometimes but like Jen likes to pretend
that she's an adventurous enough eater
she'll be like yeah I'm totally into
sushi I'm like really really do you
enjoy sushi do you enjoy it and I have
to really pinpoint she's like now I lied
i I don't so lying in that regard
affects no one if anything it makes us
both stronger right she'll be like this
chicken is so great babe like so great
and then like five minutes later she's
like oh it's like really dry
I'm gonna call right here I think she
lies more than I do
any time we talk about the future we
like don't we'll start and then we'll be
like I think you're gonna realize you
lie more than you think you like
probably I agree with that but I think
we can do it I think I can do it I think
I could do it I'm being honest with you
it's time to be honest for the week a
long week so yeah that goes I don't even
know if I know how to be a 100% honest
with myself I think my girlfriend's kind
of [ __ ] yourself and I don't know why oh
my god what if like I realized I'm the
biggest liar ever well I can tell you
honestly that I'm feeling pretty good
this is gonna be easy I really don't
take videos but I do it anyways one of
the things I've decided to do this month
because I want to challenge myself to
not drink alcohol I want to ask Jen now
that I have the opportunity to know how
she really thinks so she can't lie if
she thinks I can actually do it so
remember that 30-day alcohol challenge
yeah so I'm gonna start that so you
don't think I can do it I want you to be
able to and I want to be there to
support you but I don't think you could
do it I'm about to go grocery shopping
with Steve and this is something that I
usually really don't enjoy doing because
I'm the pickiest eater ever and I feel
like Steve is secretly judging me while
we go shopping but he doesn't say
anything he's just like being slightly
passive-aggressive let's do salmon
really you don't want like a new kind of
fish no no I don't it's the only kind of
fish you ever had you ought to try
something new I don't
life is short and I'm being honest I ate
dessert before dinner hopefully we can
both be honest about whether or not we
like this meal I don't know if you guys
knew she was a hip hop dancer dude all
right moment of truth I don't claim to
be the best cook but let's see if you
like should be honest with me about this
that's good
I really like that you're good at making
salmon what do you think it's [ __ ]
fantastic better than the one you burned
earlier this is Steve and I are about to
go shopping I'm pretty nervous Steve do
you think this is cute sure you have to
be a hundred percent honest no you all
my honest it kind of looks like a life
preserver making his hat
looks a little bit douchey I'm not a hat
person you are a person just not that
Jen how much longer five minutes
how much longer she said that 20 minutes
ago I thought that we did a nice job
being honest
you tend to like douchey hats I don't
like what does that even mean what's a
douchey like a bro hat like the Hat okay
so where do you see us in five years you
first I don't know where I'll be
career-wise in my journey of like self
so therefore I don't know where I'll be
with you in five years in an ideal world
let's say together right sorry it's
scary because I don't like to think
about the future I'm not sure that I
didn't answer I'm trying to not cry
because my eyes are tearing up I like to
take it day by day
yes so see how much we hate this
question Steve didn't answer the crust I
know where do you see our relationship
in five years the question I don't I
don't know in terms of my relationship I
feel like he's definitely gonna break up
with me before five years happens you
actually feel like I didn't know you
thought about like that I appreciate you
telling me that I don't anticipate doing
that at any point in the future but I'm
I'm glad you can be honest with me
I feel like in five years we should
still be together happy and panic go to
like you know live in life but even more
baller than we are right now dollars so
you did it I thought we both did a
decent job it was significantly less
painful than I imagined it would be how
people do you think you would be I
thought it would be pretty bad I have
definitely realized that I do lie I've
been catching myself like maybe once a
day because of this project I am now
like oh my god I'm a liar always lying
it's definitely eye-opening it did make
me realize that I really love my
relationship you know what maybe our
relationship isn't as strong as we
thought it was and there are still some
more things that we need to learn about
each other if you think you're trying to
protect your partner by not telling them
something that doesn't end well either
do you still think you need to tell
white lies no if you're willing not to
be as judgmental for certain things all
right so it's about communication yes
it's about communication folks
[Music]